[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais été à l'aise avec l'idée
que l'on ne pouvait rien changer que
tout était écrit je crois plutôt en
notre libre arbitre
l'idée que le futur est déjà là et que
nous pouvons le capter a changé beaucoup
de choses pour moi je vais partager avec
vous comment j'ai expérimenté que je
pouvais guidé mon avenir
comment en me rapprochant de plus en
plus de celles que je suis profondément
j'ai développé ma capacité à me
connecter à ce futur déjà là en suspens
autour de nous et inversement comment en
me connectant à ce futur en suspens
je me rapproche de plus en plus de
celles que je suis pour vivre ma vie le
plus pleinement possible
c'est ce que j'appelle la transformation
en fait il y a deux mouvements en
parallèle un mouvement vers l'intérieur
où l'on regarde ce qui se passe dedans
et un mouvement vers l'extérieur où l'on
regarde comment ce qui se passe dehors
est claire ce qui se passe dedans
les deux sont nécessaires ça va vous me
suivez toujours bon pour moi
la transformation c'est très pragmatique
la mienne mais devenu particulièrement
visible grâce aux vernets où tu es là je
sors ma botte secrète
carl gustav jung éminent psychologue il
dit qui regarde dehors rêve qui regarde
à l'intérieur se réveille
le processus de transformation est le
même pour tout le monde ce qui varie
c'est ce que l'on vit et surtout la
façon de le vivre
je vais utiliser le modèle de la théorie
du co créée par auto charmeur du mighty
un institut de recherche américain
reconnu j'aime ce modèle parce qu'il est
simple et malléable et qu'il nous
connecte au futur il se compose de cinq
étapes
roulement de tambour voici le processus
étape 1
l'événement déclencheur qui entraîne la
prise de conscience au hasard un burn
out
mais ça peut être aussi un deuil
un déménagement un changement
professionnel avant je croyais que
j'étais une superwoman que je devais
être une mère parfaite une
professionnelle parfaite
vous imaginez la dépense d'énergie
d'ailleurs peut-être certains d'entre
vous sont ou ont été dans ce schéma
aussi et puis un jour mon corps m'a
stoppée
ça n'a pas été brutal ce fut progressif
pour bien me donner le temps de me
débattre pour bien me donner le temps de
me raconter que je n'allais pas flanché
pas moi connais ni m'a dit la vie si tu
continues à témoigner de ce que tu es
profondément tu te prépares un mur
massif dont tu me diras de nouveau des
nouvelles de fait c'était un beau mur
bien massif et je les prie à pleine
vitesse dans la figure
mais je n'ai pas pu lui en dire des
nouvelle parce que je me suis effondrée
c'est le moment parfait
pour se retrousser les manches ce qui
nous amène à l'étape 2 j'ai utilisé ce
temps de chaos intérieur pour mettre à
jour ses schémas de fonctionnement
kimoto bloqués l'exigence de performance
la recherche de perfection le besoin de
sécurité entre autres
ma chance c'est que je crois que la vie
est intelligente et qu'elle nous amène
ce qui nous est utile pour devenir ce
que nous sommes profondément j'ai
observé mes ressentis et ce que je
vivais le challenge c'est de se
reconnecter à son corps ses émotions ses
ressentis dit comme ça ça paraît facile
sauf que dans la réalité mon mental
occupe la place et les bons vieux
réflexes sont là tu t'es effondré tu te
croyais solide mais pas du tout ça c'est
ce que je me dis dans ma tête mais ce
n'est pas la réalité c'est juste ce que
je me raconte alors je dis stop
car ça ne sert à rien sauf à me rendre
impuissante en fait considéré que je
suis ou bien forte ou bien vulnérable
n'a pas de sens car je suis les deux à
la fois accepté que je sois à la fois en
train de souffrir et d'avancé sur mon
chemin je peux être à la fois en
confiance et avoir peur
la bonne nouvelle c'est que quand vous
prenez l'habitude d'être à l'écouté ça
va très vite et vous souriez de vous
voir vous identifier à vos pensées
l'autre jour j'étais sous ma douche un
peu préoccupé par une situation
et puis j'ai laissé mes pensées
vagabondent et et là tout d'un coup tout
devient clair et je vois comment je vais
agir
ça vous est déjà arrivé non enfin pas
d'être sous la douche mais d'avoir une
prise de conscience intempestives
en fait vous savez ce qui s'est passé
c'est tout simplement que c'est un
moment de détente ou vous laisser aller
vos pensées vous laisser l'espace ovide
créateurs c'est comme un verre d'eau
quand il est plein on ne peut rien y
ajouter
mais quand il est vide on peut le
remplir et donc sous la douche je libère
de l'espace pour accueillir quelque
chose est ce que cela pourrait être le
futur qui devient perceptible maintenant
l'étape 3 je me connecte à ce qui est
vraiment essentiel pour moi comment
ai-je envie de me réaliser
quelles sont mes talents naturels qu'est
ce que je veux amener au monde
et là je prends conscience que j'ai
besoin de deux choses de créer mon
entreprise pour contribuer plus
largement aux transformations personnel
et aux transformations des organisations
sans contrainte et d'écrire un livre
pour partager et transmettre mes
découvertes
bref contribuer aux prises de conscience
j'ai envie de liberté d'accompagner
d'être moi sauf que dans la réalité
mon futur le plus prévisible était de
terminer ma carrière dans l'entreprise
dans laquelle j'étais
on nous a appris que passé présent futur
et et chronologique alors qu'il y a dans
le présent les germes du futur le futur
est déjà présent sous forme de cygne
imperceptible 7 synchronicité dirait
young
c'est juste la matérialisation de ma
connexion aux champs d'information qui
m'entourent auchan quoi aux champs
d'informations au vide qui nous entoure
de quoi est fait ce vide de nos pensées
de nos intentions de nos inconscients
individuels et familiaux
tout cela constitue l'inconscient
collectif dans par les young et d'autres
d'ailleurs
c'est un peu comme une station de radio
les stations de radio existe autour de
nous mais si nous n'allumons pas la
radio et si nous ne choisissons pas un
canal nous n'entendrons rien c'est
pareil si nous ne sommes pas conscients
que cette masse d'information existent
et que nous pouvons choisir de nous y
connecter simplement en portant notre
attention sur ce que nous percevons
hersant tôt alors nous nous privons son
accès non seulement c'est incroyable
mais c'est super pratique
ça veut dire que cette masse
d'information est accessible puisque
elle est partout autour de nous et à
l'intérieur de nous aussi
vous savez peut-être qu'avec les atom et
les électrons qui nous constitue nous
sommes essentiellement fait de vide mais
si je suis fait de vide et si je suis
connecté au vide qui m'entourent et si
le futur est déjà là ça veut dire que je
peux le capter ça veut dire que j'ai la
main sur mon avenir commun grâce à mes
pensées grâce à mon intention de ce que
je souhaite être offerts nos pensées et
nos intentions joue un rôle essentiel
quand j'ai mais une pensée j'aimais des
particules de lumière des bios photos
tout comme mon adn en est mais ça paraît
incroyable
qui pourrait croire que penser et
intentions se matérialise
laissez moi vous raconter une histoire
étonnante à ce propos le docteur clip
baxter l'inventeur du détecteur de
mensonges a décidé un jour de brancher
son appareil à une plante aucune
réaction
alors il s'est demandé ce qui pourrait
la faire réagir
il s'est dit qu'il allait brûler une de
ses feuilles au moment même où cette
intention lui a traversé l'esprit
l'appareil enregistré un signal fort et
baxter n'avait pas encore commencé à
mettre son idée à exécution laplante
avait réagi à son intention depuis de
nombreuses autres recherches ont été
faites et montre que c'est bien
l'intention qui entraîne une réaction
nous arrivons à l'étape 4 c'est la mise
en mouvement
comment ai-je mis en action ce qui a
émergé pour moi mes intentions sont
claires je cherche un éditeur pour
publier mon livre et je veux créer ma
société
en parallèle de mon super poste en
entreprise dans les deux cas j'ai posé
un acte
cela met une information dans le champ
qui comme tout système se réorganise en
fonction j'ai trouvé mon éditeur
au détour d'une invitation d'une
collègue d'une façon improbable et pour
ma création de sociétés j'ai acheté un
nom de domaine sur internet tout en
n'ayant aucune intention de quitter
l'entreprise dans laquelle j'étais une
semaine plus tard une discussion
inattendu me fait comprendre qu'il est
temps que j'arrête de faire des
compromis
les mots n'image sociale et ma sécurité
financière à ce stade impossible de
continuer à me cacher derrière mes peurs
quand je prends ma décision et que je
signe mon départ je me retrouve envahie
d'une sensation d'énergie intérieur
vraiment incroyable et je dirais même
plus vraiment incroyable bien sûr la
mise en mouvement n'a pas besoin d'être
aussi radicale on peut commencer par un
premier petit pas du moment que l'on
concrétise une action à partir de ce qui
a émergé
j'essaie puis je regarde ce qui se passe
et je m'ajuste et enfin l'étape 5 c'est
d'incarner je sens à l'intérieur de moi
se qui s'est intégré s'est passé dans
mon corps pas par ma volonté mais parce
que j'ai ex
alimentée et cheminées grâce à
l'attention que j'ai portée et que je
porte sur ce que je vis à l'intérieur de
moins et autour de moins aujourd'hui
avec le recul je vois bien que je ne
réagis pas pareil que mon regard sur les
situations ou sur les personnes à gagner
en compréhension de ce qui est à
l'oeuvre
finalement la transformation c'est
d'assumer ma singularité assumer toutes
les parties de moi même y compris les
paradoxes
vous avez peut-être entendu parler de ce
constat scientifique dans les années 50
des singes de l'île japonaise de kochi
mais on commençait à laver des patates
douces avant de les manger
quelques temps après ce même
comportement a été observé sur des îles
avoisinantes
alors que les tribus maquette n'avait
aucun contact entre elles ça veut dire
quoi
ça veut dire que les pratiques se
transmettent par le chant d'information
si chacun d'entre nous fait un pas vers
sa transformation
son expérience devient accessible à
d'autres et petitpas après petit pas à
notre mesure nous contribuons à la
transformation du monde
avoir vécu cette expérience m'a
transformé et vous quelle attention
allez-vous porter à l'intérieur quelle
attention
allez-vous porter au signe du futur déjà
présent dans votre vie en fait le futur
que nous voulons pour nous et pour nos
enfants
ça commence maintenant merci
[Applaudissements]